[Music]
and asking you to imagine your future so
imagine yourself five years from now ten
years from now 15 years from now think
about your family think about your
relationships think about your career
really try to get vivid images in your
mind so my first question is who here
comes up with positive images just put
your hand up okay
yeah that's quite normal and now I'm
going to ask you four specific questions
number one if you're currently married
what is the likelihood that you will get
divorced 10% 50% 90% so don't fill up
just keep it in your mind number two how
optimistic are you about your family
slightly optimistic very optimistic not
so optimistic number three how
optimistic are you about the other
people and other families in this room
and number four what is it chances that
you will prosper financially and
professionally and now let's see how
other people answer these questions will
start with marriage so in the Western
world divorce rates are about 40% that
means that out of every five couples
walking down the aisle two will end up
splitting their assets so but when you
ask newlyweds about their own likelihood
of divorce they estimated at around zero
percent and even divorce lawyers who
should really know better hugely
underestimate their own likelihood of
divorce now turns out that optimists are
not less likely to divorce but they are
more likely to remarry in the words of
Samuel Johnson remarriage is a triumph
of Hope over a series now statistically
if you're married you're more likely to
have kids and we all think that our kids
will be especially talented these by the
way are my own kids Olivia and Leo and
their
very bad example of the optimism bus
because they are especially talented and
I'm not alone out of every four people
three said that they were optimistic
about the future of their own families
that 75% but only 30% said that they
thought that the next generation will be
doing better than the current one and
that's a really important point because
we're optimistic about ourselves we're
optimistic about families we're
optimistic about our kids but we're not
so optimistic about the guy sitting next
to us and we're somewhat pessimistic
about the future of our country and the
ability of our leaders and we call this
private optimism versus public despair
one reason for this is control we feel
we have control over our own destiny we
feel we can steer the wheel in the right
direction and so we're optimistic about
our own future but we don't feel we have
control over where our country is going
or where our leaders are taking us and
so we're less optimistic about those
issues if you take small business owners
for example in the u.s. out of every
three small business owners only one
small business will remain standing in
five years so that's 33% but when you
ask small business owners about their
own likelihood of remaining standing 80%
say that it will be them that will
succeed that means that half of them are
going to be unpleasantly surprised when
they say okay so these are all examples
of what we call the optimism bias which
is a tendency to imagine the future to
be better than the past of present and
on average to overestimate our
likelihood of experiencing positive
events in our life and underestimate the
likelihood of experiencing negative
events this does not mean that with
every aspect of our life we're
optimistic it doesn't mean that everyone
is optimistic but on average we find
this in about 80% of the population and
we find it in females we find it in
males we find it in different
countries around the world in Western
countries in non-western countries so
it's quite a global phenomena usually
when people hear about this the first
question that they ask is well this is a
good thing or is it a bad thing and the
answer is yes so on the positive side if
we have we're optimistic we have
positive expectations of the future that
reduces stress and anxiety which is good
for our physical health and it's also
good for our mental health what we find
is that the 20% that don't have the
optimism bias about half of them tend to
have depression where people with mild
depression actually do not have a bias
that doesn't mean that they're more
accurate in predicting the future it
just means that sometimes they're err on
the side of optimism and sometimes the
err on the side of pessimism so they
don't have a systematic bias the other
10% tend to not have an optimism bias
but are not depressed and the other
advantage of optimism is that if we have
positive expectation it enhances
motivation right if I think my company
is going to succeed then I try harder
and it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy if I think well it's not going
to work out I'm not going to get that
promotion whether I don't try and I'm
more likely to fail so those are the
positive aspects but there are also
negative aspects because if we
underestimate our risks we might not
take precautionary action we might not
wear a helmet when we bike we might not
buy insurance when it's a good idea we
might not go to medical screenings but I
think that over evolution humans have
evolved to be optimistic because on
average the positive outweighs the
negative and if you think back to our
ancestors to get out of the cave and
hunt they have to imagine that there's
something out there for them to find and
their ability to come back right to
leave Africa and explore the rest of the
world they had to imagine that there's
something that they would find and
had to imagine that that is something
that may be better than what they
already had and people are not always
aware of how to framework or the fact
that they have an optimism bias a lot of
times people would come into my lab and
say no no I'm a realist I'm a pessimist
this is especially true in the UK but
then when you test their expectations
and look at the outcome you find the
optimism bias but becoming aware of this
can really help us for example to be
more effective in communicating because
we understand how other people's brains
work to restore our motivation when
needed by for example creating
anticipatory events and by protecting
ourselves from the negative consequences
of over-optimism
to protect ourselves we can't make the
bias go away the illusion will not just
go away by knowing about it and to
really kind of get that message across
I'm going to end with this example which
is an example from vision illusions so
if you look at this what do you see it
looks like an upside down photo of a
smiling girl right okay let's test it so
when you look at it like this it's quite
clear that something is wrong right it's
called the patcher illusion because it
was first demonstrated on Prime Minister
Margaret Thatcher who wasn't known for
her smile and the reason that it works
is that we're very very good at
perceiving upright faces we do it all
the time right we see upright verses
around us and any little small something
weird is something that we can perceive
very well however we are not experts at
receiving upside down upside down faces
right we don't do that so it's really
easy for us to not see these kind of odd
things but what is the point of this the
point of this is that although explains
the allusion to you and you saw it
unfold
you're still tricked right so knowing
about it doesn't make it go away and
it's no different for these cognitive
biases optimism bias I showed you the
data you probably believe it it doesn't
mean that it's going to make it go away
but what we can do is plan ahead knowing
that we have it
[Music]